Привет! В этом уроке мы разберёмся со средой, в которой мы с вами будем работать, по сути, весь курс. Что это такое, как это устроено, где что лежит. В общем, проведём такой общий обзорный тур. Сразу скажу, этот урок мы собрали по вашим вопросам, те, которые наиболее часто возникают. Он такой дополнительный к первому, по сути, после первого вы уже можете начинать работать, но если хочешь подробнее разобраться со всем этим делом, вот, пожалуйста.
Я уже отмечал, что Antigravity — это EDM, это среда разработки. Сразу хочу отметить, наша цель здесь не в том, чтобы вы стали программистом. В каждую кнопку нам вникать совершенно не нужно, заучивать всё это дело тоже, но общий каркас знать полезно.
Следующие 9 уроков модуля мы все находимся именно здесь. Если вы понимаете, где у вас файлы, где агент, где его правки, какие там, не знаю, плагины использовать, как кастомизировать модель, работать вам будет сильно легче.
Итак, начнем с базовой вещи. Что такое IDE? То есть Antigravity, по сути, является IDE.
IDE — это программа, в которой разработчики собирают цифровые продукты. Редактор текста, список файлов, терминалы, истории изменений — всё в одном окне.
Исторически это инструмент программистов.
Современные IDE стали очень удобной базой для работы с IDE-агентами, потому что файлы проекта, терминал, браузер и сам агент — все живут в одном пространстве и видят друг друга.
Агент может открыть файл, дописать, запустить команду, посмотреть результат — всё в одной среде, без копирования контекста туда-сюда.
Это, конечно, очень удобно.
Именно поэтому мы ведем курс в IDE, не в чате GPT, не отдельно в Клоде.
В чате вы каждый раз объясняете контекст заново, в IDE-агент сам видит ваш проект.
И Antigravity — это как раз такая среда разработки.
Сделали ее Google, в эту среду встроен и агент как часть системы.
Он не прикручен каким-то плагином сбоку.
Вы работаете в том же окне, где лежат файлы вашего проекта.
У вас открыт терминал, запускается браузер, контекст никуда не теряется, агент видит всё, что видите вы.
Давайте коротенько сравним с другими средами, потому что есть и другие программы для этого.
Вы могли о них слышать.
Самая, наверное, базовая, популярная среда — это VS Code.
Это среда универсал, популярная у разработчиков.
Агенты в нее подключаются плагинами.
Копилот, Клодкод и так далее.
Мы устанавливаем плагин и пользуемся любой, по сути, нейросеткой внутри VS Code.
Работает, работает хорошо, полноценно, но там агент — это дополнение, соответственно, вам его нужно покупать, будет отдельно.
Я, например, чаще всего именно с Клодкод работаю.
У меня есть на него подписка, поэтому я могу не использовать антигравити.
Я могу просто открыть VS Code и туда подрубить Клодкод.
Далее у нас курсоры.
Это среда, изначально заточенная под агентов.
Это сильный инструмент, но там платная подписка.
Она стоит 20 долларов в месяц.
Не купишь по какому-то супер выгодному тарифу.
И в целом лимиты там, я бы не сказал, что слишком лояльные.
Хорошая штука, популярная, но однозначно платная и далеко не самая дешевая.
Там также можно отдельно Клодкод подключить.
Можно использовать внутренние модели по подписке доступные.
Но, в принципе, ты курсором не можешь пользоваться, не оплатив сам курсор.
Тут тебе придется платить дважды, если ты хочешь своим тарифом Клода пользоваться.
Дальше у нас Клодкод.
Отличный инструмент, красивый инструмент, приятный инструмент, но не слишком удобный именно для наших задач.
Зачастую еще им пользуются через командную строку.
Тоже не очень удобно.
Их собственное приложение Клодкод не позволяет нормально работать с артефактами, с файлами текстовыми, которые создаются.
Там, ну, это, в общем, неудобно делать.
Их неудобно править, неудобно смотреть.
Короче, вроде как классная штука.
Возможностей там больше, чем если ты используешь Клодкод через антигравити или расширение в каком-нибудь VS коде или в том же антигравити.
Но при этом не дает ровно того функционала, который нужен нам в рамках нашего процесса.
И антигравити.
Агент там стоит в центре среды, сам ходит в браузер, внутри доступно несколько моделей, помнит всю вашу сессию.
Давайте теперь, почему мы выбрали именно его для прохождения курса.
Главная причина – это соотношение возможностей к цене.
Прямой аналог на рынке – это курсор с подпиской, например, PRO.
Она стоит уже 20 долларов в месяц и, ну, лимиты там меньше, чем на том же антигравити.
Антигравити же можно купить на платимаркете, например, ссылка будет под этим уроком в том числе.
И там в районе 1000 рублей ты покупаешь эту подписку на полгода.
При этом в антигравити есть и Клод Опус, и модели Gemini от Гугла тоже одни из сильнейших.
Клод на данный момент покруче, но, блин, Gemini тоже отличные модели.
Получается, что у тебя в одной среде сразу две передовых модели за, ну, примерно, как бы 170 рублей в месяц, если поделить 1000 на 6.
На Гугле 2 терабайтов хранилище держать, есть возможность пользоваться Deep Research, нам он обязательно будет на этом курсе нужен.
Мы будем с помощью него проводить глубокие исследования.
Также это Gemini, чатовый ассистент, который позволяет там и расписание ваше составлять, и почту проверять.
Ну, в общем, все, что взаимосвязано с гугловскими сервисами.
Ну, и, конечно, там, генерировать картинки в Nano Banana Pro, Nano Banana 2, тоже популярные сейчас нейросети.
А по поводу того, как покупать этот антигравити, в целом, что важно отметить.
Это продукт Гугла, поэтому сам антигравити напрямую в России не работает.
Это зарубежный сервис.
Чтобы им пользоваться, нам нужен КВМ.
Также нам нужен аккаунт не из России, поэтому если вы на свой аккаунт будете покупать этот антигравити, подписку, то, скорее всего, она у вас просто будет недоступна, у вас не получится это сделать.
То же касается и Клода, его тоже вы можете купить.
Поэтому берем именно аккаунты продавца.
Если вы все-таки берете что-то на свои аккаунты, то берите на аккаунты не основные, не те, которыми вы пользуетесь, потому что есть риск утечки данных.
Чтобы этим пользоваться, нужен нам VPN.
Сразу оговорюсь, берите собственный сервер за границей.
Не массовые, готовые КВМ сервис.
Сразу объясню, почему на вот этом купленном каком-то сервисе VPN сидите не одни вы.
На том же самом серваке сидят и другие люди.
В общем, со временем такие серваки просто палятся.
Их и сервисы палят, и наши отечественные службы безопасности.
Поэтому они часто отваливаются, они компрометируются, и в целом это вообще нестабильно работает.
Мы сейчас живем, к сожалению, во время ограничений, соответственно, постоянно ты меняешь эти КВН, что-то не работает, где-то ты там ищешь обходы и так далее.
И в этом контексте очень важно понимать, что когда что-то глючит в этой связке, там, Google, обход, плюс твой собственный компьютер, плюс антигравити, нужно понимать, где именно что сломалось.
Если КВН не ваш, непонятно, кто виноват, в чем проблема, да и в целом намного быстрее работает именно свой сервак.
Google зачастую капризничает, провайдер может урезать пакеты, может быть, у вас вообще роутер в доме перегрелся.
И вы гадаете, в чем вообще проблема, что не так, и тратите огромное количество времени на то, чтобы просто выяснять, почему ты не можешь сейчас работать.
Если у вас свой сервер, это исключено, вы уже знаете, что все там настроено, все работает, и никто, кроме вас, ну и, возможно, ваших родственников, кому вы раздали доступ, им не пользуется.
Вот, так что облегчаем себе работу, облегчаем себе жизнь, исключаем вот эти узкие места, в которых могут возникнуть проблемы.
В описании под видео будет актуальный гайд, как арендовать сервер и поднять свой КВН, занимает это, там, минут 15.
Один раз настроили, все работает со всех устройств, обязательно этим нужно заняться.
С вводными можно заканчивать, давайте теперь пройдемся по самой среде.
В общих чертах посмотрим.
На самом деле, все, как в привычных программах, боковые панели, центральная рабочая область, панель снизу, примерно так же, как в Figma, просто содержание другое.
Итак, погнали подробнее, что у нас здесь.
Тут у нас разные панели, например, первый из них это Explorer.
Это вот вся наша папочка, которую мы открыли.
Здесь у нас различные файлы, их может быть какое угодно количество, по сути, это просто файлики.
Сразу отмечу, что такое MD-файл.
Это то же самое, что TXT, просто текстовый файлик, в котором у нас этот текст сверстан, разбит на заголовки первого, второго уровня, на всякие там таблички и так далее.
По центру, как вы уже могли заметить, у нас открывается сам этот файл, мы можем его посмотреть, покрутить.
Здесь с нажатием правой кнопки мыши открыть превью.
Посмотрите этот файл уже в нормальном виде, в удобном.
Далее справа у нас сам чатик, я думаю, несложно догадаться.
Давайте пройдемся по этим левым вкладкам.
Что у нас здесь?
Тут у нас есть CodeSearch.
Полезная штука, иногда пригождается.
Вот, например, смотрите, есть у меня OKR1.
Просто скопирую это.
Бывает, что огромное количество файлов, вот, например, здесь сейчас у меня уже много артефактов.
Там исследования, персоны, проектная документация и так далее.
Все это текст и все это много текста.
Мне нужно найти что-то конкретное, поэтому открываю CodeSearch, сюда вставляю.
И вот вижу, что у меня в PRD-MD есть запуск продукта.
Это строчка, он все подсвечивает и находит.
Периодически нужно этим пользоваться, поэтому здесь эта штука находится.
CodeSearch.
Далее у нас Source Control.
Вам это не надо, это для разработчиков.
Это для того, чтобы на GitHub изменения синхронизировать.
То есть там пушить, чтобы другие члены команды тоже могли всем этим делом пользоваться.
С этим мы разберемся попозже.
В рамках первого модуля нам это точно не нужно.
Дальше Run and Debug.
То есть запустить и отдебажить.
Ну, по сути, это для разработчиков.
Запускать скрипты, проверять, что все работает.
Дальше Remote Explorer.
Также можно подключаться к внешним каким-то файловым хранилищам через эту штуку.
Сейчас нам это тоже не нужно.
Следующая панель это Extensions, то есть расширение.
Я особо ими не пользуюсь, но мы в конце видео еще посмотрим, какие расширения есть, какие вам, возможно, стоит скачать.
Открываем здесь, ищем, устанавливаем.
Я, например, пользуюсь Cloud Code.
Просто сюда вводим Cloud, качаем его.
После чего открываем вот этой иконкой и здесь проходим верификацию.
Вас перекинет на сайт Клода, на сайт Anthropic.
Там вам нужно будет авторизироваться, просто зайти в свой аккаунт и сюда обратно вас вернет.
Уже можно будет работать.
Дальше у нас вкладка Testing, то есть проводить, опять же, своих скриптов, тесты.
Нам это не нужно.
И следующая, это Cloud Code, она появилась у меня, когда я просто скачал это расширение.
У вас его не будет, если вы клодом не будете пользоваться, поэтому эта штука такая необязательная.
Ну и в целом здесь, на самом деле, не так много.
Ваши локальные сессии, ваши сессии в вебе.
Можно открыть тут и продолжить разговор с нейросетью.
Вот он попытался потянуть сессию, но у меня, видимо, она там удалена от неактуальной данной.
Здесь снизу также опубликовать на GitHub проблемы, которые у вас есть в коде, но у вас не будет, скорее всего, кода.
Так что и проблем тоже.
И в целом с этим все.
Возвращаемся на ту вкладку, на которой мы чаще всего будем работать.
Что здесь есть?
Здесь создать новый файл, создать новую папку, обновить.
Иногда добавляются новые файлы, здесь они не появляются.
Просто нажимаем обновить и чекаем, что у нас тут файлик появился.
Ну и кнопка, чтобы все папки свернуть.
Иногда их много, начинается неразбериха.
Вот можем сюда нажать, все папки свернутся.
Дальше.
Что еще есть интересного?
Тут у нас есть, например, Open Agent Manager.
Это менеджер агентов.
Вы можете в этой среде с ними взаимодействовать.
То есть, если ваша задача в том, чтобы просто общаться с агентом, как там, с тем же чатом GPT,
вы можете это делать вот через это окно.
Он точно так же будет хранить весь контекст.
Он будет связываться с конкретными файлами, конкретными папками.
Просто, ну, возможно, там, для вас в этом интерфейсе это будет удобнее делать.
Потому что таких папок и проектов у вас может быть много.
Внутри каждой папки у вас, может быть, с агентом несколько диалогов.
Они будут выполнять с одними и теми же там файлами несколько разных задач.
Соответственно, здесь слева у вас все эти папки будут отображаться, все ваши агентские среды.
Тут вот сами диалоги, каждый из них можно продолжить, вести здесь, переключаться, смотреть,
кто там закончил работу, кто только начал и так далее.
Единственный минус, тут нельзя нормально открыть файлик и посмотреть с ним поработать.
Вот, например, есть у меня чат, Updating Research.
Тут я вот просил его скил изучить, но, в общем, это неважно.
Те файлы, с которыми он взаимодействует, они здесь справа появляются.
Если мы нажимаем вот на этот сайт бар.
Любой из этих файлов, да, мы можем открыть, посмотреть, почитать.
Здесь вот красным отмечается, что он менял, что он добавлял.
Но править все это мы здесь не можем.
Можем комменты оставлять для того, чтобы он там этот файлик потом поправил.
Если мы нажимаем View File, то посмотрим без всей этой фигни.
Но править здесь мы файлики не можем.
Нам придется все равно это открывать в эдитере.
И нас перекидывает, ну, в обычную ту же самую среду.
Так что поправить мы ничего там не можем.
Да, можем посмотреть.
Но, не знаю, мне кажется, это не очень удобно.
Я пользуюсь всегда вот таким режимом.
Возвращаемся в нашу привычную среду.
Что еще здесь у нас есть?
Здесь через эти кнопки можем скрывать и возвращать различные панели.
Тут, например, иногда бывает, что вот так вот скрывают и не знают, как потом это дело достать.
Вот, здесь эта панелька открывается.
Далее тут есть также возможность подвязать браузер.
Если в хроме у вас есть расширение для этого, то вот, пожалуйста, этим всем делом можно пользоваться.
Он будет сам ходить по сайтам, тыкать ссылки, изучать и так далее.
Иногда это тоже нужно.
Он неплохо так тратит токены и, ну, делает это не слишком быстро.
Хотя и на самом деле, вот если сравнивать вообще, в принципе, со всеми агентами,
именно Gemini модель делает это быстро и круто.
Опус чуть более вдумчива, но значительно дольше.
Также тут у нас есть настройки.
Это именно настройки среды.
Это то, что тут перекочевало из VS Code, потому что Antigravity собран именно на основе VS Code.
Соответственно, это настройки среды разработки.
Нам вообще там ничего не нужно.
Есть у нас Antigravity User Settings и на них можно посмотреть поподробнее.
Что здесь есть?
Вообще в агенте у нас есть Strict Mode.
Это режим, когда у вас, когда нужно включить повышенную безопасность.
Это строгий режим.
Каждое действие, каждой правки, он будет у вас спрашивать, можно ли это делать.
Нам такое, разумеется, не нужно.
Здесь также Review Policy, терминал команды Auto Execution.
Это, ну, по сути, автовыполнение действий с кодом, с вашими там другими файлами.
Я здесь поставил Always Prosits, чтобы он всегда, ничего не спрашивая, просто выполнял то, что я попросил.
Но на самом деле все равно он там спрашивает.
Есть тут ограничения, которые не обойти, но, тем не менее, вот это стоит поставить.
Также тут можно добавить ряд команд терминальных, которые всегда можно выполнять.
Те, которые никогда нельзя выполнять автоматически, они будут отменяться.
Автооткрытие редактируемых файлов и так далее.
На самом деле ничего здесь особо больше полезного нет.
Customization мы также можем подключать сюда скиллы.
Далее, здесь у нас снизу отображаются те чатики, которые у нас были до этого открыты.
Вот тут они.
Здесь я попросил изучить директиву, развернуть ее, он это сделал.
У нас этот чат сохранился.
Смотри, иногда чат не сохраняется, иногда в Antigravity не получается зайти.
В общем, бывают разные проблемы и они могут быть связаны как с VPN, так и с работой Google серверов, так и с самим Antigravity.
Как это обычно бывает, когда мы получаем очень много и очень дешево, работает это не всегда идеально.
Поэтому, что в таком случае можно сделать?
Заходим на сайт Antigravity, его загрузки, просто пишем в Google скачать Antigravity.
Здесь он по умолчанию предлагает самую последнюю актуальную версию.
Но не всегда эта самая последняя актуальная версия работает круто.
Поэтому View Previous Releases.
И тут у нас можно попробовать скачать версию чуть постарше.
Здесь опубликовано огромное количество версий.
Ну, по сути, все, которые выходили.
Не советую брать слишком раннюю, потому что, скорее всего, она вообще работать не будет.
Antigravity может вообще не давать ничего делать, пока не обновишься.
Еще также, когда ты купил аккаунт, бывает, что авторизоваться не получается.
Просто там, ну, тебя возвращает в Antigravity, а там ничего не происходит.
Это также решается загрузкой предыдущих версий.
Но конкретно эту информацию лучше всегда уточнять у продавца.
В целом, если вы купили аккаунт, что-то не работает, нужно уточнить это у продавца.
Потому что я могу сейчас сказать, какую конкретно версию качать, а окажется, что уже не эту.
Поэтому спрашиваем у продавца.
Продавцов мы только надежных советуем, те, у которых сами берем.
Соответственно, можно быть уверенным, что вам там ответят, что вам нужно сделать.
Дальше.
Что у нас здесь в чатике есть?
Тут у нас есть возможность откатиться до конкретного сообщения.
То есть, например, вы попросили что-то исполнить Antigravity, а он сделал полную фигню.
Поменял ваши файлы, все удалил, создал новые.
Короче, не то, что вам нужно было.
Поэтому здесь мы можем нажать Undo Changes up to this point на вашем сообщении.
Принять.
И у вас восстановится все, что было на момент, когда вы это сообщение писали.
Туда, если нажмем, можем посмотреть, какие изменения были внесены.
Здесь у нас, тут у нас работу терминала.
Но нам это не нужно.
Артефакты, то, с чем тут он взаимодействовал, с какими файлами.
И здесь на браузере открыть окно браузера и в нем продолжить взаимодействие.
Как мы это делаем?
Нажимаем Launch.
Открывается браузер.
Здесь Refresh.
Видим, что страничка появилась.
С этим всем делом можем взаимодействовать.
Здесь что-нибудь писать, гуглить и так далее.
Открывать конкретные страницы.
Он уже будет понимать, что нужно работать с ними.
Тут также можно сделать скриншот.
Сразу он автоматически закинется сюда, в наше окно ввода.
Посмотреть, что там в консоли.
Упомянуть, чтобы он использовал конкретно эту страницу.
Понимал, что с ней надо взаимодействовать с браузером.
На этом все.
Можем его закрыть, обновить.
Увидим, что он тут пропал.
Дальше.
Что еще у нас здесь есть?
Сюда можем добавлять файлы, упоминать конкретные файлы, правила, директории и так далее, которые у нас уже есть в этой среде.
Например, могу упомянуть какой-нибудь файл.
Вот выберем Files, Person и так далее.
Он сразу их прикрепит.
И также есть Workflow.
Мы сейчас посмотрим, как это работает.
Здесь модели у нас Gemini 3.1 Pro, High, Low, Flash, Sonnet, Opus.
Мы сейчас посмотрим, чем они отличаются отдельно.
Здесь могу только подчеркнуть, что есть отличительная особенность.
С Gemini, если ты взаимодействуешь, ты можешь записывать голосовухи.
Это удобно.
Если используешь Клод модели, Sonnet или Opus, то голосовые ты не можешь записывать.
Opus круче, Sonnet попроще.
Это то, что еще можно здесь отдельно отметить.
Ну, подробнее мы с этим разберемся.
Хотим новый диалог запустить, нажимаем New Conversation, пишем, общаемся.
Здесь у нас снизу отображаются все наши диалоги.
Также здесь можно нажать Past Conversations, то есть прошлые диалоги.
И он показывает вам вообще в любых ваших средах вашей диалоги.
Не только в этой.
Также здесь сверху при нажатии три точка есть MCP сервера, кастомизация.
MCP сервера это штука, которая позволяет взаимодействовать с разными отдельными продуктами.
Вот, например, есть у нас Notion.
И Notion работает по своим собственным правилам.
Есть у него там слева эта панель, есть файлики, есть какой-то набор того, что можно создавать.
Заголовки первого уровня, квоты и так далее.
То есть это приложение, которое по своим правилам работает, как-то там устроено.
И если ты просто говоришь, если ты просто скажешь там нейросети, зайди в мой Notion и что-нибудь там опубликуй.
Она этого сделать не сможет.
Она не понимает, как она работает.
Поэтому все крупнейшие владельцы, создатели приложений создают MCP сервера.
Это такая модель взаимодействия твоей нейронки и конечного приложения.
Через этот MCP сервер, через это связующее звено нейронка понимает, что такое создать новый документ,
что такое создать новую страничку, что такое создать там заголовок первого уровня и так далее.
С Figma через MCP мы также взаимодействуем.
Если мы просто скажем, задизайни мне там какую-то страницу, он не поймет даже какую-то фигму открыть.
Но через Figma MCP он уже понимает, как она устроена, как взаимодействовать, как что-то там создавать и так далее.
Если мы перейдем на MCP сервера, то увидим, что тут уже огромное количество различных приложений.
Здесь можно найти нужное.
Мы будем подключать Notion MCP.
Я покажу, как это сделать и в Роке, и в Гайде.
Также, когда мы какие-то подключения создаем, здесь у нас есть Manage MCP Servers, мы можем посмотреть все, что у нас подключено.
Поэтому, если что-то не работает, какое-то подключение, можно здесь узнать почему и попробовать заново его настроить.
Но сейчас у меня очень долгое обновление, поэтому это мы опустим.
Сейчас вообще нет нужды в это углубляться.
И еще одна вкладка, которая здесь есть, это Customization.
Как мы можем кастомизировать вот нашу среду, работу с агентами.
У нас есть правила, rules, то, чему агент должен всегда строго следовать.
У нас эти правила описаны в Gemini MD.
Они будут дополняться, расширяться, видоизменяться, возникать новые и так далее.
Он, как правило, автоматически понимает, что есть эти правила и сюда их добавляет.
Если хотите быть максимально уверенными, что у вас все работает строго и четко, можете здесь эти правила новые создавать.
Также, что я хочу еще отдельно отметить, это Workflow.
Неплохие штуки. Можно здесь автоматически создавать порядок действий.
Вот есть у меня, например, директива, инструкция для агента, которая запускает брифинг.
И здесь у меня описано, что нужно сделать.
Там собрать полную картину, твоя роль, ты сеньор, UX, лид.
Есть там пользователи, функциональность, технические ограничения.
Все эти вопросы нам нужно закрыть.
Вот как бы конкретные инструкции, что ты должен делать.
Мы можем, перетаскивая в чате, упоминать эти инструкции, просить их запускать.
А можем сделать Workflow.
Как мы это делаем?
Вот, например, у меня есть брифинг, и он, соответственно, должен быть по какой-то конкретной задаче.
Проведи мне брифинг, если я хочу создать новый Telegram.
Поэтому тут я создал просто в своем Workspace новую задачу, новый Workflow.
Тут мы указываем, как он будет называться.
И как этот Workflow выглядит.
У нас есть Description, ну, просто для нашего понимания, что делает этот Workflow.
И описание.
Я здесь ему указал, пробрифуй меня по BriefMD директиве.
То есть, ну, запусти ее выполнение.
И дополнительно указал, что он должен спросить сначала, на какую тему проводить брифинг.
А не просто на какую-то рандомную.
Вот.
И когда я создал этот Workflow, я могу вернуться, вот, например, в агента.
И здесь, нажав вот Slash, он мне сразу предлагает уже готовый Workflow.
У меня есть Workflow Briefing.
Я могу нажать запусти бриф.
Все.
Я могу этот Workflow запустить.
Он понял, что нужно с BriefMD связаться, прочитал его и теперь говорит.
Прочитал директиву, прежде чем начнем, на какую тему делаем бриф.
Если у вас очень много разных директив, много разных задач,
не всегда, когда ты ему говоришь, там, сделай мне это,
он понимает, что нужно с конкретной директивой связаться.
Таким образом, вы можете выстраивать для себя Workflow
и выполнять эти действия всегда, ну, с одинаковым объемом вводных,
с четким пониманием у него, какие конкретно файлы нужно открыть,
с чем нужно взаимодействовать.
Итак, мы досконально вообще всю среду изучили.
Давайте теперь еще немного теории по агентским процессам.
Вот как выглядит типичный агентский проект, ну, конкретно в нашем случае,
потому что мы его разворачивали вот по этой архитектуре, по этой структуре.
У нас проект, это не какая-то программа, это вот набор инструкций для агента
и того, что он по этим инструкциям для нас создает.
Там будут файлы с брифом, ресерчем, персонами, все, что вы соберете за весь модуль.
Плюс папка с директивами, которые вы будете давать агенту.
Из чего вообще вот типичный агентский проект в нашем случае состоит?
Первый, это, конечно, Gemini MD.
В нем описано, какая у нас должна быть архитектура, какие там папочки создать,
с чем мы будем дальше работать.
У вас уже выполнен этот этап, вы это уже сделали и увидели, что у вас эти папочки появились.
Дальше, вот согласно этой структуре, что он создает?
Следующий уровень, это директивы, это конкретные инструкции под задачи.
Они у нас описаны в формате MD файлов, точно таких же текстовых.
Там описаны инструкции для агента, что ему вообще нужно сделать.
Там готовые команды, которые агент читает и выполняет.
Следующая папка, это env.
Это доступы, это такая секретная папка.
Мы ее, как правило, никому не передаем.
Это пришло к нам из разработки.
Там лежат ключи, которые позволяют получать доступ к каким-то внешним сервисам.
То, чем мы, как правило, делиться не готовы.
И дальше, следующий уровень, это наши артефакты проекта.
Их может быть какое угодно количество.
Это, по сути, все то, что по нашим задачам создает сам агент.
Например, просим агента провести бриф, он его проводит.
И с его итогами создает нам файлик в этой среде.
Они у нас будут лежать просто в корне среды.
Если ты хочешь, чтобы у тебя была отдельная папочка со всеми артефактами
в Gemini MD можно описать в архитектуре.
Делай, чтобы у нас отдельно эти папочки создавались для всех артефактов.
И тогда не будет этого шума.
Давайте еще раз про архитектуру.
Буквально два слова, чтобы вы понимали, почему файл выглядит именно так.
Это называется трехслойная архитектура, директивы, сам агент и скрипты.
Скрипты это слой с исполняемыми файлами.
Это могут быть скрипты на питоне.
В первом модуле у нас таких не будет, но вообще есть тоже всякие процессы,
как, например, я не знаю, транскрибировать какое-нибудь видео.
Для этого можно собрать свой скриптик, вернее, это агент для вас делает.
И потом он этот скрипт будет переиспользовать.
Мы бы могли просто как с чатом GPT общаться без всей этой архитектуры,
но все-таки это нейросеть, она работает по вероятности.
И чем больше шагов делает сам, тем выше шанс того, что у нас где-то что-то отвалится,
где-то он ошибется, уйдет не в ту сторону.
Ну и в принципе все это дело надо менеджерить, чистить периодически
и понимать, что у тебя и как работает.
Поэтому нам обязательно нужна архитектура, нужна понятная прозрачная структура,
как нам, так и агентам.
Теперь давайте поговорим про модели, какие и для чего использовать.
У нас на выбор несколько моделей Gemini и несколько моделей Клода.
Давайте сразу отмечу основное.
Круче всех работает Клод Опус.
У Клода также есть модель Sonnet, она работает на самом деле не сильно хуже.
И в целом для любых задач, если у вас возникает вопрос, что использовать,
скорее всего Клод Опус лучше всего с этим справиться.
Клод Опус это самая мощная, соответственно самая тяжелая модель,
жрет много токенов и она у вас быстро может закончиться.
Если хотим использовать Клод, но у нас много итераций,
мы понимаем, что предстоит большая работа,
мы можем использовать Клод Sonnet.
Эта модель немного проще.
Самый лучший результат это, конечно, Клод Опус.
Также у нас есть модели Gemini, это тоже хорошие модели Gemini Pro.
Поскольку это модели от Google, на них лимиты значительно щедрее.
Я думаю, это понятно.
Ну и в целом это тоже передовая модель.
Она хорошо работает, поэтому иногда даже у меня бывает, что Опус тупит.
Я выбираю Gemini 3.1 Pro.
У нас есть Gemini Flash, Gemini Pro Low и Gemini Pro High.
Коротко о них.
Gemini Flash из моделей Google самая тупая, но при этом самая быстрая.
Я бы не сказал, что она прям совсем глупая.
Она уступает своим братьям старше, но все-таки это тоже хорошая модель.
Если нам нужно что-то переформулировать, какие-то черновики, мелкие правки,
то Flash отлично с этим справится без урона по нашим лимитам.
Дальше у нас модель Gemini Pro Low.
Pro модель умнее, круче в целом.
И Low это такая золотая середина.
Это когда у нас там повседневные задачи,
когда нужно побыстрее, когда нужно побольше всего сделать
с достаточно щедрыми при этом лимитами и хорошим качеством исполнения.
Мы можем использовать Gemini Pro Low.
При максимальной ответственности, максимально сложных задачах
мы можем использовать Gemini Pro High.
Из гугловских эта модель самая мощная.
Она по сути по мощности сравнима с Cloud Opus,
хоть и немного ей уступает.
Но при этом, да, чем мощнее модель, тем дольше она думает.
Если у тебя какие-то мелочи, нет смысла использовать Pro High.
Ты просто долго будешь ждать на выполнение того,
что Flash за пару секунд тебе может сделать.
Поэтому подводим итог.
Выбираем Cloud Opus.
Если не хотим сильно тратить на нем лимиты, выбираем Cloud Sonnet.
Если лимиты на нем закончились, но у нас ответственная задача,
выбираем Gemini Pro High.
Если это повседневные какие-то таски,
там у тебя будет куча итераций,
ты собираешься долго с ним работать,
долго его мучить, выбираем Gemini Pro Low.
И в конечном итоге, если совсем какая-то мелочь,
то выбираем Gemini Flash.
Но на самом деле я все время на Pro High Gemini
использую, и нужно постараться, чтобы добиться истечения лимитов.
Лимиты там достаточно объемные.
Так что если используешь Gemini,
не думаю, что стоит размениваться на модель Low.
И последнее. Плагины.
Я, честно говоря, вообще особо плагинов не использую.
Только у меня есть там плагины для запуска своих прототипов на локальном серваке.
Но здесь нам это не нужно.
Тем не менее, отобрал для вас ряд плагинов,
которые вам могут быть полезны именно в контексте работы в агентской среде.
Это живой предпросмотр Markdown.
Там это будет немного удобнее.
С MD-файлами мы работаем постоянно.
Дальше.
Mermaid Preview.
Это если нам агент рисует какие-то схемы, диаграммы,
они будут визуализироваться с этим плагином.
Далее.
Error Lens.
Ошибки и предупреждения прямо в строке, где они появились.
Но это, опять же, наверное, больше связано с кодом.
GetLens.
Подсвечивает нам, что конкретно агент изменил,
и позволяет одним кликом сделать откат.
ToDo3.
Это штука, которая позволяет удобнее нам формировать список того,
что нужно агенту сделать.
Именно сделать это как чек-лист.
Чисто такая визуальная штука.
DotaNV.
Это плагин для вот этой папки Envy,
о которой мы уже говорили.
Он там будет подсвечивать ключи.
Код SpellChecker подсвечивает опечатки.
Если их по каким-то причинам у вас много,
то он сможет их подсветить,
потому что агент иногда может галлюцинировать,
если у вас написано что-то с опечатками.
Это может быть важно, когда у нас там какие-то аббревиатуры.
Thunder Client позволяет по API тестировать запросы,
но нам это только в четвертом модуле пригодит.
И Project Manager, переключение между разными проектами.
Я вообще без этих плагинов работаю,
но вот был запрос на плагины, пожалуйста.
Ну и MCP сервера.
Это у нас отдельно подключается.
Я показывал, где под любой крупный сервис, скорее всего, есть MCP.
Поэтому обязательно чекаем.
Также отдельно отмечу, что Antigravity создан на базе VS Code.
Соответственно, любой плагин из VS Code сюда можно закинуть
и подключить из той же самой библиотеки.
Итак, на этом все.
Мы с Antigravity полностью разобрались.
Вообще прошли по всей среде.
И плагины посмотрели, и архитектуру.
Теперь ты знаешь, как работает агентская среда,
как работает Antigravity,
что и где тебе использовать.
Этот урок такой дополнительный,
чтобы просто внести ясность.
Никакого домашнего задания не будет.
Поэтому до встречи в следующем уроке.
Пока.